this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
time since so many of you asked so
nicely in the last episode jonathan is
checking out even more of the weapons
from rainbow six siege
all right i'm gonna have to pause it
there what on earth is that
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armouries museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
wow that really they're not wrong with
the name super shorty it is in fact
super short i mean usably short i think
if you if you want it for blowing hinges
off doors short enough that you're going
to get enough pressure to actually
damage and all blow away the hinges i
wouldn't like to rely on something that
short for any practical purpose apart
from anything you're only going to fit
two rounds into that magazine tube we
get a third round out of it by chamber
loading which was you'll see a lot of
people do with tactical shotguns or
competition shotguns as well so they'll
load the first round via the ejection
port advantage to that of course is
you've got a round in the chamber right
away so if you're set upon you can fire
that round uh you don't have to carry on
loading the magazine tube the base
weapon is a remington 870 and it has a
sort of side grade kit involving a
pistol grip no butt stock and a stop
ridge pump grip not a bad idea because
with a barrel that short you've got a
reasonable chance of blowing all your
fingers off if you slip off the front of
the pump grip so that big flange is a
very good idea the real downside for
combat use apart from it being pump
action and therefore slow is the lack of
a butt stock i mean that's drastically
hampers your ability to aim
the v308 v
as in vector but 308 as in 0.308 of an
inch and if you look at the side of it
it says 7.62 nato
the vector was designed as a pistol
caliber submachine gun or carbine
depending whether it's semi-automatic or
select fire like this one and it makes a
certain amount of sense in that
configuration pistol cartridges are
relatively low recoil the super v system
in there that redirects the recoil
downwards helps keep the muzzle rise to
a minimum and somewhat reduce felt
recoil that works with pistol calibers
it wouldn't work with 762. there is no
chris in 762 nato i don't know whose
idea this was i don't know why it's in
the game making it extra ridiculous
is the drum mag looks like a surefire
style drum mag the size of the cartridge
means it's got a big a longer heavier
barrel on it as well overall then a
existing wacky submachine gun turned
into a very wacky assault rifle the
other aspect to this that's a bit of a
rabbit hole to go down is whether you
could even build a 762 version of this
design the way this v-shaped bolt is
designed i don't think there'd be room
even in this stretched version for it to
actually function correctly i'll give
them some some credit for the way it's
depicted in use because it does kind of
look like the player is hanging on for
dear life when this thing shoots
something we see quite a bit in this
game with its destructible environments
which i think are
really quite impressive by the way the
level of destruction and the sort of
tactical opportunities that opens up
were definitely the high point for me
when i did attempt to play the game some
years ago there are consequences for
that in real life and there's a reason
why we have dedicated breaching tools
firearms are not usually the best way to
get through these things what we see in
the game where the butt of a rifle is
being used to smash through some really
quite solid bits of wood i don't think
that would be feasible in in many
situations that i've seen in the in the
footage and i remember from playing if
you were to try and use it as a bludgeon
to get through a plank of wood may or
may not survive and if it doesn't
survive your rifle might be harder to
aim and if it's a ar an armalite based
system with a buffer tube and a spring
inside that buttstock you might have
actually prevented your rifle from
functioning if you managed to bend the
buffer tube now you'd have to hit
something really hard with a rifle to
achieve that but then to get through a
wooden plank you'd have to hit
really really hard if you could achieve
it you do your weapons some serious harm
in the process
we've got us bass 15. follow up to the
spas 12 of course which was a more of a
traditional shotgun tube fed design the
15 is clearly uh box magazine fed more
aping the ergonomics of the famous ar-15
i mean to be fair being a fairly
tactical breaching through doors not
just a straight run and gun type game
there would have been room there for
using the manual pump if you were going
to switch ammunition to say a breaching
round that might not have the the force
to cycle the semi-automatic mechanism
which is really the idea behind having
either manual or pump it's so that you
can default to manual operation if you
have a certain type of ammunition so
they could actually have implemented
that but i don't think they have they've
just turned it into a semi-automatic
only which is an interesting reversal
from hollywood where if a shotgun is
capable of both they nearly always use
it manually possibly to do with
reliability of cycling with blanks
mainly to do with how cool it looks i'm
thinking in particular here trinity with
her sparse 12 in the matrix where that
whole scene would have been less cool if
it wasn't getting pumped
iron sight view if you like of this is
quite an interesting one the rear sight
is deliberately mounted very far down
the carrying handle because sites that
are close together are great for quick
aiming for snap shooting weapons
intended for sort of short to medium
range benefit from a shorter sight
radius it does in theory negatively
affect accuracy at longer ranges because
you've got less fine adjustment by
having them closer together the the each
movement you make is slightly more
magnified effectively something to note
i think in terms of this being shotgun
and shotguns having their tactical role
is where we we see a big old hole
getting blown through this wooden wall
here blowing a hole through a wall and
then shooting people through it isn't
necessarily the
sop for a swat team or something but it
does speak to the ability of a 12-gauge
shotgun to
breach so to blow a lockout blow a hinge
out perhaps even help make entry if you
if you have to if you haven't got
breaching charges or a sledgehammer
famously if you had to you could use
potentially a shotgun to do it don't try
this at home though
we're dealing here clearly with a french
gign operator with a ballistic shield
and he has a revolver and i believe they
have stopped using revolvers now they
were certainly using them into the turn
of the millennium in contrast to just
about every other special forces unit in
the world it was almost like a badge of
identity of honor that they were using
these
really nicely made
manual revolvers which is what this
should be the mr37 but it's not it's a
smith wesson 586 so it's an american
equivalent to the correct french
revolver now if this was a low budget
movie or something or one
film somewhere where they couldn't get
the manual i'd say fair enough but as
this is a virtual environment i'm gonna
say why didn't you use the mr73
because that's what that's what he
should have now in the middle of a
blazing firefighting siege you're not
going to be able to really tell the
difference anyway but this is what it
should be
very very similar
also 357 magnum kind of bizarre that
it's still in use as late as it was
being that it's only six rounds and a
modern self-loading pistol well take
your pick anything from 15 to 20 rounds
now but for certain applications at
least this was still in use until really
quite recently and i'm sure they still
have them in the armories come to think
of it i don't know that i've seen one of
these
in a video game so if i'm right somebody
please put one in a game because they're
they're really cool
accessorizing revolvers is tricky
they're old technology they weren't
designed for sights and lasers and stuff
like that if you wanted a scope you had
to have a sort of a dovetail mount
adapted and as for lasers there isn't
really anywhere to mount them we've seen
grips that have a little laser built in
so when you squeeze the grip the laser
comes on what we've got in siege is
a quite old-fashioned way of mounting a
laser so you would literally put a hole
in the front of the trigger guard
wouldn't dream of it on this this
200 sort of collector piece really and
you clamp on hoping that the angle works
with it a sort of kit and then a wire
that would run around the trigger guard
or along the frame to the grip and then
when you grip the grip the laser would
come on and it's sticking out of the
front of the trigger guard so that's not
been invented by the developers of this
game that is a an old-school way of
mounting a laser to a gun that wasn't
designed to have one
right well the name says c8 sfw sfw
being special forces weapon a specific
variant of the c8 carbine canadian
equivalent to
the usm4 so this
c8 sfw that i'm holding here
this is from the dutch
contract from from demarco for the dutch
military what looks at first glance like
quite a good attempt at what it's
purporting to be if you look at it with
a nerdy eye there's quite a lot wrong
with it the notches if you like on the
on the accessory rail are far too far
apart all too spaced out so the modeling
has gone awry there and then the real
sore thumb is the barrel the iconic sfw
profile barrel is a sort of m16a2
profile so a far cry from the original
thin pencil barrel of the m16 or of the
original c7 and c8 rifles now there are
shorter barrel c8s what we've got here
is neither fish nor foul all a bit
confusing slightly unusually because i
don't believe canadian forces use the
the m26
we have the american m26 modular shotgun
system so this thing is meant to be
either mounted to a weapon as we see
here or fitted to a standalone grip
stock to use as a
handy light breaching shotgun and of
course you could use it for combat in a
pinch but that's not really what it's
for a short barrel isn't going to be
developing perhaps enough velocity for
reliable combat use that's not really
what it's for it's meant for getting
through doors primarily that those are
some mighty big holes for such a small
shotgun you're firing most likely
buckshot and the holes created in that
sort of drywall or whatever it is are
absolutely immense i don't think the
physics would allow for that equally you
probably don't want to be stood there
for five minutes while you manually blow
a hole through a wall with a shotgun in
a game that's a compromise that they've
made
[Music]
this is a really odd choice i think i
think it's the magpul version the fmg9
which was a folding submachine gun
designed to fold into a rectangular
block the very first or possibly the
second version appears in robocop ii
point being this is meant to be like the
ultimate concealed submachine gun it
folds pretty much in half the magazine
and the grip folds up and then the whole
thing folds together so it's like a nice
compact blocky item a problem with
anything like that is the time it takes
you to deploy it versus just lifting a
gun gun up from a sling or pulling it
out from a hip holster or something like
that folding guns don't make a great
deal of sense certainly not for this
kind of role more strange than that i
think is that the game doesn't even
acknowledge the folding aspect of the
gun you don't even get a cool flippy
spinny unfoldy animation as as the gun
is readied it just comes up and if you
didn't look it up or didn't know about
what it was you would just think it was
a weird looking submachine gun i don't
really know why they chose it maybe they
had specific plans for it that were more
interactive i don't know yeah it doesn't
doesn't really make in-game sense to me
what
in the hell
[Music]
all right i'm gonna have to pause it
there
what on earth is that
next up is the mark 17 cqb mark 17 being
the us military designation for the scar
heavy the special forces combat assault
rifle the f is silent and quite what a
combat assault rifle is supposed to be
i'm
not quite sure well i am sure someone
desperately wanted the acronym to spell
scar because it's manly i suppose so the
idea here would be
the punch of 762 with the compactness of
something more the size of an m4 or even
shorter actually mark a mark 18. so it
does it fits it very much the mould of a
modern rainbow six game not at all
surprised to see it here one of the
first several firearms to introduce this
idea of
not black solid black coloration
actually not being great for camouflage
you're much better off with a
greenish color this sort of mishmash of
different shades of brown this is
actually what they look like they're
very rarely one solid color because the
different finishes the different
materials end up looking different they
reflect reflect the light differently
apart from anything else i've been doing
this for perhaps 12 years in a
professional capacity and i have never
once seen even as an idea this style of
ballistic shield where it's just a
transparent piece of plexiglas or
ballistic glass whatever this is meant
to be that attaches to the rifle
directly the great benefit would be that
it gives you a great field of view not
interrupted by kevlar or ceramic or
steel or whatever you would normally use
for a ballistic shield the massive
downside is how incredibly unwieldy this
would make the weapon we constantly
struggle to add functionality to
firearms to make them more capable
whilst keeping weight down and strapping
a bit of double glazing to your rifle
seems like a spectacularly poor idea you
either want a ballistic shield a full
height or maybe even a half height one
to give you comfortable coverage of your
torso at least or you want a rifle you
don't want a rifle and a ballistic
shield combined it's been tried and when
i say it's been tried it's been tried as
far back as the 1530s with gun shields
that were purchased by among others
henry viii we have quite a few in our
collection and they are iron or steel
and wood shields with a match lock
breech-loading gun mounted in the middle
of them and those didn't catch on for
very good reason and
this wouldn't either
i'm pausing again now i've seen it in
action i'm even less convinced so it's
got some sort of estimation
marks down the side i don't know what
they're for answers on a postcard and
then when it gets hit rather than take
impacts and kind of spider or take
damage but still be there it just kind
of shatters into into oblivion and you
no longer have it it's it's one of the
more bizarre things i've seen in a
supposedly somewhat realistic
first person shooter if anyone has seen
any real world inspiration for this
please put it in the comments because
i'm kind of fascinated but at the same
time slightly afraid to see it
that is a take on the hmk grenade
launcher adopted in the us as the m320
and it's in its standalone configuration
with a butt stock and a pistol grip
which is increasingly how these
formerly mostly under barrel launches
are being used rather than unbalance and
make heavier the gun you sling it or
even holster it as a separate weapon and
you use it as needed and then you go
back to your rifle i don't have one to
compare there's something not quite
right about the configuration of that
the sights don't look as i remember
seeing one stranger than that are the
munitions being used there now i believe
that's some form of breaching ammunition
where it somehow burrows into a
breachable wooden structure or whatever
whatever it happens to be and then blows
up after a delay so it's almost like a
remote breaching shotgun interesting
idea i'm not aware of any real
ammunition like that existing though i
think it would be really quite
problematic to get to work and quite
dangerous if it didn't work there's not
really a need if you're breaching they
don't know you're there so you get as
close as you need to shouldn't really
need to breach from a distance but i
don't do this for a living so
maybe that's been mooted in some
concept way but i'd be surprised
for those of you wondering what this
funny-looking beige mp5 is this is the
mli mid-life improvement configuration
for the mp5 so this isn't a third-party
manufacturer or an aftermarket accessory
kit this is heckler and [ __ ] trying to
keep their 1960s vintage mp5
relevant some would say that they should
be doing that by adding a bolt hold open
device so that you don't have to do the
rather slow hk reload with the old slap
that we've we know and love so the
changes are to do with accessories but
other than the cosmetic change of making
it fashionable and brown
so the gun hasn't changed they're just
finishing them in a different color
fitting an accessory hand guard fitting
a royal rail adapter still got the old
iron sights on there and in fact the
same claw mount mounting system
underneath but rather a cost-effective
way to keep the mp5 somewhat competitive
with modern submachine guns but they
could they could perhaps have gone
further with that to keep it in the race
but then submachine guns are not widely
purchased for this kind of role anymore
you're better off with a an intermediate
rifle caliber really for most
applications but the mp5 is an absolute
classic i can't help feeling that hpk
have ruined the aesthetic appeal of it
with this update we can't blame siege
for that
right a shotgun clearly i'm not super
hot on over under 12-gauge shotguns i
must admit they're really more of a
sporting
gun this is over and under which i guess
makes it look a bit more tactical than a
side by side but really a gun like this
has no place
in a tactical shooter as far as i'm
concerned two shots cumbersome reload
for the type of application that that's
being used for when this thing is
reloaded if the player has only fired
one round it will only eject the fired
case there's some clever mechanical
jiggery pokery going on in there that
will only punt out the fire case so that
although it might look like a mistake is
definitely not there's a nice touch when
this thing is opened up because you can
see the sort of decorative pattern of
polishing that's done to the breech end
of the barrels so that's something you'd
see on a
relatively decent sporting shotgun which
presumably this is supposed to be
although you wouldn't normally see it on
one with black polymer tactical looking
furniture
someone has to
annoy slash amuse me put an acog four
power optical sight on this thing why
you would you wouldn't do that major
issue of course is the magnification
and the field of view if you're trying
to look through this and use it at close
range try walking around your house with
a pair of binoculars
in front of your eyes so i'm not really
the biggest fan of this thing so this
thing's supposed to be firing 12 gauge
slugs and i think it does a reasonable
depiction of that if you were fighting
at close quarters with a shotgun
something like buckshot would seem to me
to make more sense the slug is
devastating don't get me wrong the idea
of slugs as far as i'm aware was for one
thing shooting engine blocks on cars and
for longer range i'm not entirely sure
that slugs would be the choice if you
were using a shotgun in this situation
but we really are in fantasyland here
thanks very much for watching the
firearms of rainbow six siege please
join us again next time here at gamespot
also we at the royal armories have our
own youtube channel do go and check that
out and as always we'll have links in
the description for ways that you can
support the museum and keep us doing
what we're doing thanks very much
[Music]
you